almost every assassin's creed game
introduces a new protagonist in its
historical fiction
and in the case of valhalla that's
legendary viking leader aval
but who is this mysterious
battle-hardened character well here's
seven things we learned about the newest
ac
protagonist able is an established
leader
the viking raider is forced to lead
their people out of war-torn and
overcrowded norway
in the hopes of settling in anglo-saxon
england an order that tool calls for a
legendary leader and so from the outset
of valhalla you'll be embodying just
that in our hands-on session of the game
we played around three hours of the game
from part way in
so we weren't able to see exactly where
avor's journey begins
but ubisoft told us that it was
important to have the character
established in their strength and
leadership among their people narrative
director darby mcdevitt told gamespot
associate editor jordan ramy they wanted
to start out with a character who's
already an expert and a legend
and that they needed to be someone who
people already had a deep respect for
aval's age and motivations mcdevitt
explained that while assassin's creed
games traditionally start with a boy in
his late teens
who finds his strength and maturity
avail is 26-27 when the game starts
and already legendary in their clan he
said there's a bit of a cool arrogance
that comes with that
but there's also a sense of humor and a
bit of a leader who doesn't suffer fools
lightly
and maybe gets a little hot when things
don't go their way has a very tactical
mind
but is also a bit selfish they want
glory for him or herself
they want to be known and want to be
honored as a brave and courageous
warrior
evil's brutal combat style that whole
glory angle certainly seems to fit well
with avor's combat style which is far
more brutal and aggressive than that of
cassandra or alexius
abilities are back and they'll bind to
your triggers and execute using
adrenaline
but they pack a gorier punch than they
did in the age of the greeks
there are also new finishes that you can
use like stomping an enemy to death once
you've knocked them down
aval's arsenal is also more versatile
than you'll be used to
they can dual wield any weapon in each
hand or two shields if you prefer
and weapons function differently
depending on whether they're in your
primary or secondary hand
that's not to say avor doesn't still
have a full suite of stealth abilities
up his or her sleeve
although being far larger than their
greek protagonist counterpart they do
look a little funny trying to crouch
behind
a cart to perform a stealth
assassination aval's stoic personality
in our three-hour hands-on this
characterization largely rang true
while our session was primarily combat
focused a handful of main and side
quests gave us a further look into
aval's personality in my playthrough she
was indeed revered by those around her
generally kind-hearted earnest righteous
diplomatic
confident and somewhat stoic but not
devoid of humor
she appeared less jovial and more mature
than cassandra or alexius which comes
with the territory of her position
but she still had quips to counter her
friends in lighter scenarios
you're very strong you're very large
evil's romantic opportunities we even
had the opportunity to engage in a love
scene where you get the option to
accidentally or deliberately forget the
name of the gentleman you just ducked
out for a private moment with
we've been told romantic options in
valhalla will be more serious
if that's the way you want to go with
them this time around but it still seems
like there's room for the casual
approach if you prefer that
for your avor i shall as well growth
here
ruther i'm not brutal
bullies balls you thought i was my
brother
to be honest i did not think at all
abel's flexible dna
but what about the elephant in the room
that is the conceit behind being able to
play as a male
or female avail and to switch between
them at any time
that was one of our biggest questions
out of the demo and we were told that
the core reason behind that
is a mystery but basically the genetic
memory stream wherein you access an
ancestors memories
is conflating the dna of male and female
evil which is why there's some
uncertainty as to aval's gender
we've been assured that it'll all make
sense by late in the game
the mystery of aval's deadly ambition
there's plenty more to the mystery of
avor
a feature alluded to heavily in
ubisoft's latest trailer called avors
fate
that weaves together elements of the
viking invasion into england
as well as supernatural and political
facets
the suggestion that aval's ambition and
drive to achieve glory may be their
undoing
is certainly intriguing and important if
we're assumingly set for another 70 plus
hour epic adventure
if you want to know more about how it's
all gonna go down do check out our other
features on assassin's creed valhalla
including our full hands-on impressions
and let us know who your all-time
favorite ac protagonist is and why down
in that comment box
you